hello freak [ __ ] dude I when I was in
the back after the fight right so again
I'm with heard about this oh yeah
telling about this cleared up now so
many people in blow me up so again I'm
with James Crawford American Berto and
I'm in the back and they're saying how
good Conor did I'm like anti great you
know I thought you knew even better you
know I'm surprised you know you did well
and Showtime when we go do this post
fight show thing so I'm going and I see
Nate Diaz things by himself like no
one's really buying he's by himself he's
on his phone and I see him I think Oh
same fraternity UFC guys there's no UFC
representatives there really there's
like Dana I didn't see him at the fight
I just figured hey we're brother yeah
what's up man but I was going towards
him because he looked busy I was gonna
go towards him and whether he wanted my
help or not I figured I'd know a few
things about marketing the next fight
for him is Conor I'm assuming he's there
to sell that fight that should be in the
next fight Conor verse Nate Diaz 3 the
trilogy that's the fight so I wasn't go
to him because I saw some interview it's
kind of hating on Conor and I would have
spun it the other way he should have
celebrated Conor and what he did winning
rounds against the best of all time in
saying look I beat him up worse than
Floyd now we're gonna do this trilogy
I'm gonna end him faster than Floyd did
like that should be the sell I was you
know talk to him about this so I see him
out karna I'm like oh in the right come
on Bren we gotta go Mike let me just say
what's up to this guy and I'm like yo
Nate bro how about that fight man you're
next biggest fight in UFC history
brother and he starts laughing he's like
oh hell no how [ __ ] stupid do you
look now and I'm like I'm like cough gun
like what he's a how stupid do you look
talking all this [ __ ] I'm like whoa what
are you doing right now what the hell
are you doing right now and he keeps
talking I go Nate he doesn't like that
stupid he wasn't against the best box of
all time and then Nate psyche didn't win
round he gave him one round I'm like all
right man either way so he gave him he
won rounds though what do you what are
you doing and he just keeps talking [ __ ]
and then he starts like talking about my
career and I'm like what is going on
right now
I go Nate as mad at you I went Nate I
have no issues with you you're pointing
your gun at the wrong
what are you doing right now you should
be selling this fight against Conor not
me I'm not the guy I said I'm in skinny
jeans and gucci boots for god sakes what
are you doing right now you know I'm
saying right and then like Showtime was
like come on let's go boys I'm like
Jesus Christ man keep going I was just
embarrassed by the situation cuz he kept
talking I kept doing this and I this is
what this is the part I left out this is
what triggered him he was talking that I
Lori came here because people like shop
let's go guys they didn't want to you
know a fight so I shop let's go and I he
keeps talking I didn't like Nate use
your words I can't understand a word
you're saying use your words
oh right assets you know it Liz for
whatever if I set him off but I've no
issues with Nathan so that's when it got
ugly yeah then he kept talking [ __ ] and
I was like what are you gonna do what
are we doing here and he kept doing this
I'm like well what the [ __ ] is happening
I was so embarrassed cuz the Showtime
guys like oh my god who is that guy Mike
that that's the guy who supposed to
fight Connor next they fought before
like and why see what was wrong with him
what's wrong with him I'm like it's just
so embarrassed my god
no I have no issues with them do you
think that Connor wants that fight I do
you think that's a good money fine I do
I think it's the only fight I think you
know I think it's the the true winner
cuz at those those fights at 70 are
toss-up one and one is whatever neither
one should be finite seventy at 55 a
trilogy fight makes sense for the belt
it'd be the biggest pay-per-view of all
time I think it's the only fight that
makes sense you can't do could be toning
Kevin Lee there's just not big enough
stars to get to be because kabhi hasn't
made their way true and he's not ready
to fight he's just you know he's never
done that so how can you sell could be
right now like so let's say just in a
perfect world you want to could be
versed Connor and you go on this world
tour trying to build khabib up go to
rush you go all over kinda wants to
fight him in Russia crazy how do we know
he's gonna make weight and doesn't pull
out so he's out of the equation right
now he needs to come back fight someone
else so he needs to get his body sorted
out and he's afraid of some [ __ ]
Rockhold was saying that his liver shut
down I read in an interview apologize I
didn't hear him say yeah he said that
his liver shut down when he was cutting
weight for the Michael Johnson fight and
the next fight after that he didn't make
weight his body shut down for the
Ferguson fight and they cancel a fight
I'll tell you what though I might to be
flying the conversation for me to get
the [ __ ] together I'm not even entertain
the idea of him fighting Alex my Kevin I
like Kevin Lee he's bad package he's a
bad dude but the thing is he speaks well
he looks the part talks a lot of [ __ ]
he's great dressed as well like he has
all the makings of your next superstar
yeah and he realizes now especially in a
Conor McGregor era you got to talk a lot
of [ __ ] yeah Floyd said it best like you
just can't win fights you gotta sell
yourself listen Kevin Lee is only I
think 25 he's young 25 or 24 yeah
he'll find out he's 24 25 um super young
right now remember how brash Conor was
when he first got to the UFC very
similar he's like 26 I believe okay so
he's 24 September 4th he's almost 25
he'll be 25 in a couple of days he's
super talented looks better every time
you see him so he's essentially like
somewhere around Connors age when Connor
is a year younger than Connor we're
starting our first burst on the scene
and Connor was nobody back down nobody
knew who he was we do I'd seen him on
the internet and from fights in England
and I knew was really talented I
actually went back and forth with him
yes oh yeah so there's a few people who
knew about him but it was nothing like
what you see now nothing right Kevin Lee
down the road is a 135 pounder who talks
a lot of [ __ ] he's a bad [ __ ]
great he looks great
speaks well built like a brick [ __ ]
speaks well speaks well african-american
dress as well Chuck change the box just
check any can [ __ ] fight so what's
the biggest thing that fight with Conor
McGregor down the road you need you need
more time by here you right down the
road this might be for Conor like but he
could do it he Hanabusa out to me Kevin
Lee is your next big thing however Kevin
leavers Tony first since that told me so
goddamn good it's a great fight and
here's another one Tony 1st and down the
road 20 Ferguson can talk some [ __ ] to
Tony Ferguson is very smooth Tony
Ferguson is very confident she's also
weird oh he's
here's that weird vibe you get that
weird vibe oh yeah I'm so intense but
like guys like no glasses Wing Chun and
[ __ ] yeah he does all these weird moves
where he's like it flowing on the ground
going around he does a lot of weird [ __ ]
but his endurance is off the charts he
cuts a shitload of weight and does it
like a prophetic second descent can
capitalize the lamp and he wins by
knockout he also wins exciting very look
at the guys he's beat - it's a tough
test for Kevin - very tough test both
very good to me as far as like potential
like superstardom those are the guys
Kevin Lee is but that's the guy right
now I think yeah maybe but if Tony
Ferguson becomes the interim champion
starts talking all kinds of crazy [ __ ]
his star will rise man don't you belong
just demonstrating rising and then
becoming like a straight-up superstar
[Applause]
[Music]